Hallo Stefan. Wir stehen hier noch vor dem Salon.
Richtig.
Sind noch erquickt von einer musikalischen Woche mit dem Zapfenstreich, oder? Hast du es dir ganz angesehen?
Nein, nein. Ich habe, ich habe diese Woche nur die Kondensate in den Abendnachrichten geguckt. Ich habe also weder Olaf Scholz, halbstündige, ich stehe vor Kühnert und vor Mütze, dich und erzähl aber nochmal, was ich für dich da draußen im Eichsfeld mache. Rede mir angehört, ich habe Merkels Zapfenstreich-Rede nur in diesem kleinen Ausschnitt die Fröhlichkeit im Herzen gehört, habe mich sehr drüber lustig gemacht und habe auch sonst nichts weiter im Original geguckt. Du kannst mir also gerne von deinen beschwingten Erlebnissen erzählen. Du hast ja auch noch diese Gala geguckt.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Also jetzt müssen wir genau bleiben.
Beginn von.
Ich habe mir auch diesen Zapfenstreich nicht angesehen. Aber als Hildegard Knee-Fan habe ich mir natürlich die Blasmusik-Version angehört von Für mich soll es rote Rosen regnen, die Merkel sich gewünscht hat. Man hatte ja einige Probleme bei der Beschaffung der Noten. Du hast den Farbfilm vergessen von Nina Hagen, war überhaupt nicht vorrätig. Das war gar nicht arrangiert für eine Blaskapelle. Bei Für mich soll es rote Rosen regnen gab es zwar Noten, aber die mussten erst mal bestellt werden. Und das dauerte eine Weile. Und so hatte man nur kurze Zeit, das einzustudieren. Aber ich fand, das war auf jeden Fall gelungen. Auch wenn dieses Lied sich nicht besonders eignet. Für mich soll es rote Rosen regnen für die Blaskapelle. Die Musik ist ja nicht von Hildegard Knef, sondern der Text. Die Musik stammt von Hans Hammer Schmidt, der zum Beispiel auch verantwortlich ist für die Melodie der Schwarzwaldklinik. Und viele Schlager. Und der hat mit Hildegard Knef ganz gut zusammengearbeitet. Und die haben sehr, sehr, sehr schöne Chansons gemacht. Und ja, ich war aber ein bisschen traurig, dass Merkel sich ausgerechnet von Hildegard Knef was aussucht. Denn ich finde Hildegard Knef toll und will nicht, dass Merkel das auch gut findet.
Ich glaube, sie wollte auch dich ärgern. Wahrscheinlich. Sie gibt ja immer Rätsel auf, glauben alle. Alle Beobachter glauben ja immer, das Orakel hat gesprochen, was will sie uns damit mitteilen. Ich fand aber die eine Beobachtung nicht schlecht, dass sich Merkel für zwei Frauen entschieden hat. Abseits des ihr Vater war Pastor, deswegen musste sie nochmal in Kirchenlied oder so. Aber genau, zwei Frauen, Heldegard Knef, so gestandene Dame, Frau von Welt und dann Nina Hagen. Aber Nina Hagen als junge Frau, wie sie nochmal ein Thema thematisiert, wo sich sehr viele westdeutsche Beobachter fragen, das Lied kannte ich gar nicht, jetzt lese ich erst mal mir den Text durch, ah darum geht es da und so. Also dass sie da so eine Brücke geschlagen hat, fand ich gar nicht so schlecht. Ich will es nicht überinterpretieren, aber in der Hinsicht gelungenes Ding, dass ich mir natürlich trotzdem nicht angeguckt habe.
Ja, Hildegard Knef ist jedenfalls eine sehr emanzipierte Frau gewesen, eine Frau, die sich nie hat sagen lassen, was sich jetzt gerade gehört, die sich nicht um Konventionen geschärt hat, die viel mutiger war als Merkel im Prinzip. Also die viel klarer Kante gezeigt hat. Also ja, ja, ja, ja.
Guck mal, so wie du jetzt sagst, ah, sie hat meine Hildegard Knef benutzt, sitzt ja wahrscheinlich auch Nina Hagen zu Hause und denkt, was? Erlaube Merkel.
Ja, bei Nina Hagen ist ja auch ziemlich viel durcheinander inzwischen.
Genau, sie hat sich ja damals auch verabschiedet aus dem Fernsehstudio, indem sie einfach Meischberger, glaube ich, was sagte, pipapo, und hier, ich gehe jetzt. Und dann war es das im Grunde, man hat sie seitdem nie wieder gesehen. Und da liegen im Grunde bei beiden so ein bisschen die Fragezeichen, aber warum hat sich Merkel jetzt dafür, seid ihr auch so ein bisschen gestanden?
Ja, ich glaube, am Ende kann man da immer so groß hermeneutisch dran gehen und jetzt Texte interpretieren und glauben, dass da irgendwas drin steht. Es sind am Ende gerade bei so Hymnen wie für mich soll es rote Rosen regnen, auch Lieder, die im Zweifelsfall auf jeden zutreffen. Ja, genauso wie Gerhard Schröder My Way genommen hat. Auch das trifft irgendwie auf alle zu. Jeder kann immer glauben, er sei diesen einen Weg da gegangen. Und ich finde auch, My Way ist ein bisschen zu groß. Also das kann man nicht machen. Also Frank Sinatra und Gerhard Schröder, das ist halt schon noch mal eine andere Kategorie, würde ich sagen.
Aber wenn My Way dann zu Gazprom führt und so.
Ja, ja, genau. Also da muss man schon ein bisschen vorsichtig sein da. Weil für mich soll es rote Rosen regnen. Das ist auf jeden Fall auszuhalten. Und ja, dann gab es noch diese tolle Gala. Die Bild-Zeitung veranstaltet ja immer eine große, dreistündige Werbesendung im ZDF. ZDF räumt da dann Platz ein. Es ist total absurd. Und jetzt werden vielleicht Leute sagen, naja, aber die helfen ja nur den Kindern. Das hört man ja dann auch immer bei Twitter. Liest man sofort, ja, aber die helfen ja den Kindern. Da würde ich schon mal ganz klar sagen, also wer Kindern in Not spenden will, hat da alle Möglichkeiten und braucht dafür nun wirklich nicht die Bild-Zeitung. Da gibt es sehr gute Organisationen. Und da kann man sich mit drei Mausklicks perfekt informieren, wo das Geld hingeht, was damit angestellt wird. Und, und, und. Niemand braucht die Bild-Zeitung dafür. Nun gibt es also diese Spendengala, ein Herz für Kinder im ZDF, immer von der Bild-Zeitung organisiert. Und eigentlich ist das so ein großes Reinwaschungsprogramm für all das Schlimme, was man in der Bild-Zeitung ein Jahr lang gemacht und geschrieben hat. Und jetzt treffen sich alle zum versöhnlichen Fest und sammeln dann 20, 25 Millionen. Und skandalös ist tatsächlich, dass dort Schwesig, Baerbock, Habeck und der designierte Kanzler Olaf Scholz aufgetreten sind. Also das muss einfach nicht sein. Und ich würde auch noch mal ganz klar machen wollen, es kann heute jeder Politiker auf Bild verzichten. Vor 25 Jahren war das, glaube ich, nicht möglich. Also da musste man in irgendeiner Weise mit dem Teufel paktieren, wenn man an die Macht wollte. Heute, wo sich das so ausdifferenziert hat, wo wir wissen, dass ein Felix Lobrecht-Podcast eine Million Hörer erreicht, da muss man nicht bei Bild TV die ganze Zeit auftreten. Das machen die ja auch laufend. Und man muss vor allem nicht bei so einer Reinwaschungsgala mithelfen, weil das ist wirklich primär eine Werbesendung für Bild. Und es geht dann nicht um irgendwelche Kinder oder so. Und so entstehen dann solche Fotos, wo dann da zu sehen sind Baerbock, Habeck, Scholz, Döpfner, dann noch dieser komische Tennisspieler, dessen Namen mir immer einfällt. Und noch irgendwie eine Jurorin von der Höhle der Löwen. Und die seriöseste Person auf dem ganzen Bild ist Iron Shear hinten in der dritten Reihe.
Ja, also ich habe, wie gesagt, nur peripher konsumiert. Manuela Schwesig hat gestern so ein kleines Selfie mit Baerbock gemacht. Allen einen schönen zweiten Advent. Vielen Dank allen, die gestern Hashtag ein Herz für Kinder gezeigt und für Kinder in Not gespendet haben. Diesen Tweet habe ich eigentlich ignoriert. Aber darunter hat der Göttli, Daniela Göttlich1, keine Ahnung, 50 Follower, aber immer gut hier auf Twitter, darunter geschrieben, vielen Dank, dass es so viele Kinder in Not gibt. Ausrufezeichen. Das habe ich dann favorisiert. Das finde ich sehr witzig. Ja, es ist halt einfach eine Veranstaltung, bei der ich mich auch mittlerweile frage, wieso kann man sich der Bild dann nicht entziehen? Warum kriegt Matthias Döpfner, von dem wir wissen, dass er sich als letzte Ausgeburt der Demokratie-Verteidiger gegen die Diktatoren in Berlin wenige Kilometer...
Also am Samstag, am Tag der Gala, hat die Bild-Zeitung noch mal gemacht, hier, das sind die Lockdown-Macher.
Die drei, genau.
Hat da drei Wissenschaftler vorgeführt. Und dann noch die Politiker, die dort auftreten, noch mit dazu. Also es ist total absurd.
Also wurden sie erpresst, die Politiker? Ich frag mich das ernsthaft, ob wir bei der Bild hier noch was Schlimmeres vermuten müssen. Oder es ist...
Also, vulgärmarxistisch könnte man noch sagen, die Knechte der Kapitalinteressen haben jetzt den Kotau geleistet. Also auch das ist so zu sehen. Ich finde es auf jeden Fall sehr dramatisch. Und ich finde auch dann, dass es eine ganz furchtbare Doppelmoral ist, weil all diese Politiker, die jetzt da aufgezählt wurden von uns, immer das Thema Hass im Netz ganz groß machen. Und dann treten sie auf dort, wo wir es mit einem Platz zu tun haben, das jeden Tag aufs Neue wieder hetzt und was und bezogen auf Minderheiten und sonst was. Und ich meine, dass da irgendwelche B-Prominenten auftreten und dass Riccardo Simonetti wahrscheinlich alles machen würde, um ins Fernsehen zu kommen. Das weiß ich ja. Und trotzdem schreit er dann noch, ich bin für Diversity oder so. Aber das geht halt für Politiker nicht. Und da gelten andere Standards. Und das finde ich einfach skandalös. Und das muss einfach auch nicht mehr sein. Also die Stimmen, die gewinnen ja keine Stimmen damit. Und ich glaube, man könnte Springer viel stärker ignorieren und könnte Springer das auch spüren lassen. So wie Helmut Kohl früher einfach den Spiegel ausgesperrt hat und den Spiegeljournalisten sagte, ne, ihr kommt hier nicht mehr mit. So könnte man das, glaube ich, sehr, sehr gut auch mit Springer machen inzwischen. Denn die mediale Macht ist doch lang nicht mehr so groß. Und man sieht es ja auch, Springer verwandelt sich in einen anderen Konzern, in einen sehr mächtigen und erfolgreichen Konzern. Aber die Macht der Beeinflussung ist nicht mehr so groß, wie sie gemacht wird mitunter.
Ja, ja, da heißt es von Donald Trump lernen und den Kampf aufnehmen gegen die Medien. Ich hätte mir von Alena Baerbock wirklich gewünscht, dass sie mit sich nicht vereinbar ihr Buch und ihr Wahlprogramm zum Thema Kinder dort auslebt. Ich habe aber 27 Millionen gesammelt. Denn 27 Millionen, das ist dann doch ein bisschen peinlich. Wenn Springer wenigstens käme und sagte, ja, der Schäfer hat bei uns eine Milliarde geschenkt bekommen und dafür keine Geschenkungssteuer bezahlt, dann ist eine 27-Millionen-Einsackung nichts. Das ist ja peinlich eigentlich.
Also ich bin ja auch immer sofort bereit, keine Steuern zu zahlen, wenn ich dafür dann zwei Prozent spenden soll.
Dazu übrigens heute Gerhard Schick. Ich habe die Blätter gelesen, um es schon mal anzuteasern, bevor wir sagen, was wir gelesen haben.
Ich habe sie auch gelesen, ja.
Aber nicht mit, oder?
Nein, ich habe sie nicht mit auch dabei, aber ich habe den Artikel, den du meinst, auch gelesen.
Fast hätte ich nämlich gedacht, ich sage lieber Wolfgang Bescheid nicht, dass wir uns da doppeln, denn Gerhard Schick fährt ja gerade eine gute Kampagne.
Stefan, ich hätte auf jeden Fall gesagt, wenn wir ihn beide nicht genommen hätten, dass wir noch mal darauf hinweisen, dass man ihn lesen sollte. Aber umso besser, dass du ihn mitbringst.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut. Dann, bevor wir euch sagen, was wir gleich im Salon lesen, lesen wir noch kurz einen Tweet. Er ist in diesem Moment, wo ich ihn vortrage, sechs Minuten alt und hat schon über 2000 Pfaffs. Er stammt von Kevin Kühnert und er lautet im Wortlaut, Nikolaus ist, wenn Wünsche erfüllt werden, ihr wolltet ihn, ihr kriegt ihn. Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach, Spritze.
Für mich wirkt es eher so, als sei Knecht Rupprecht bei mir aufgetreten und hätte mich ausgeschimpft. Denn ich wollte Karl Lauterbach nicht. Ich sage das ja ganz klar. Ich gehöre nicht zu Lauterbach-Hassern oder so, aber ich kann diese Glorifizierung nicht er tragen und finde sie auch nicht berechtigt. Und ja, ich hätte auch gedacht, dass es andere gute Gesundheitspolitiker in der SPD gibt, die dieses Amt hätten gut ausfüllen können. Und ich bin mir sicher, dass es sie gibt. Es ist eine große Partei. Und man hört ja auch schon mal von anderen Leuten, die sich zum Thema Gesundheit äußern. Also es ist ja nicht so, als sei da Karl Lauterbach der einzige Berufende. Und ich finde diese Wahl nicht besonders glücklich. Meine einzige Hoffnung, die daran geknüpft ist, ist, dass Karl Lauterbach, wenn er so ein Ministerium leiten muss, dann hat er nicht mehr so viel Zeit, um ständig im Fernsehen aufzutreten und muss vielleicht nicht auch noch in Comedy-Formaten rumspringen.
Ja, es ist ein bisschen, also wir wissen, Olaf Scholz ist der Koalitionsvertrag sehr wichtig. Und wir wissen, wie wichtig Politik an insgesamt Loyalität ist. Dafür braucht man keinen Donald Trump. Es könnte sein, dass Karl Lauterbach und Olaf Scholz hier einen echten Ehevertrag abgeschlossen haben. Du kannst unter diesen Bedingungen in meinem Kabinett Gesundheitsminister werden. Denn ja, es hat auch ganz wenige Vorteile für Olaf Scholz, aber auch viele Nachteile. Der Vorteil ist Sichtbarkeit. Das Problem mit Karl Lauterbach ist so ein bisschen, er hat sich bei einem sehr wichtigen gesundheitspolitischen Thema auf eine Seite geschlagen und hat diese Seite wie Herr Menth verteidigt. Im Grunde wie so ein renitenter Sachse, der irgendwann nicht abrücken will von seiner Position und händeringen nach der nächsten Studie verlangt. Er hat natürlich ein besseres Auswahlverfahren. Er liest nur das, was aus Harvard kommt und so, während man in Sachsen einfach alles liest. Das ist ein echtes Problem, finde ich, denn irgendwann ist Corona vorbei und wir brauchen gerade beim Thema Gesundheit vermittelnde Positionen und keine Hartleinerei. Und wenn wirklich jemand glaubt, Karl Lauterbach sei die Stimme der Vernunft und nicht der Hartleinerei gewesen, da fehlt es dann auch an Aufklärung. Das muss man ehrlicherweise mal sagen. Die Pandemie hat nicht nur sozusagen biologische Gewissheiten, sondern auch ein paar soziale Gewissheiten mitgebracht. Die sind nicht mehr zu diskutieren. Das ist einfach Realität, mit der wir leben müssen, auch wenn wir uns das schöner wünschen. Und Karl Lauterbach hat keine gute Figur gemacht in dieser sozialen Problemlage, neben der biologischen.
Das ist etwas, was gänzlich ausgeblendet war. Die jungen Leute wurden ausgeblendet von Lauterbach. Und es gibt sehr viele Widersprüche, die er produziert hat. Aufgrund auch der vielen Auftritte. Also man könnte da jetzt irgendwelche Kompilationen zusammenstellen und zeigen, wie sich da Aussagen widersprechen. Aber darum geht es mir jetzt auch gar nicht im Einzelnen. Aber ich glaube auch, dass es zu spät von Lauterbach auch war, sich plötzlich mit der SPD zu identifizieren. Also dass man zu lange auch diesen Span-Kurs einfach mit unterstützt hat, ohne Not. Also dass man das März, April, Mai, wegen mir auch noch, im Jahr 2020 tut, wenn diese Pandemie beginnt, wenn wir sehr ratlos vor diesem Phänomen stehen. Aber dass man damit einfach 2021 nahtlos so weitermacht und dann zum Teil auch absurde Tweets absetzt und Studien wirklich nur so kurz überfliegt und dann mitunter zu sehr, sehr eigenartigen Auffassungen kommt oder immer so Schnellschüsse, wo dann ein Trosten sagt, das müssen wir jetzt mal abwarten, das wird jetzt noch zwei bis drei Wochen dauern. Aber solange würde ich gerne warten, bis ich dazu mich konkret äußere und Lauterbach aber schon nach 37 Sekunden fünf Tweets gesendet hat, dann halte ich das nicht für eine besondere Krisenkommunikation. Und wenn man dem die ganze Zeit folgen würde, wäre man permanent im Panikmodus und würde denken, ach du Scheiße, jetzt ist aber wirklich aus mit uns bald. Und das finde ich nicht besonders gut. Und das wird hoffentlich anders werden, denn so kann man nicht dann die Bundesrepublik informieren. Das kann man vielleicht noch auf dem Twitter-Profil machen. Da kann jeder so ein bisschen frei drehen. Aber das finde ich dann eher schwierig, wenn das jetzt hier stattfindet. Na ja, man wird sehen. Also ich glaube auch, dass dieser allgemeine Wunsch nach Lauterbach bei Twitter hoch ist, aber dass der nicht in der allgemeinen Bevölkerung so hoch ist. Und damit meine ich jetzt nicht, die die Lauterbach hassen und die Corona leugnen und so, sondern ich glaube, dass auch viele in der Bevölkerung eher sagen, ja, Trosten finde ich ganz interessant oder was, Cisik und zu sagen, aber dass sie bei Lauterbach auch so ein bisschen eher mit Skepsis reagieren. Vielleicht auch, weil man ihn zu oft gesehen hat und weil er auch merkwürdige Ansichten vertreten hat. Und wenn es ja dann auf so eine soziale Ebene kommt, dann wird es ja mitunter wirklich ein bisschen verrückt. Also, dass Lauterbach dann irgendwie sagt, ja, der Elon Musk, der könnte jetzt den Hunger der Welt beenden, wenn er jetzt einfach sein Geld spenden würde. Und wir haben aber auch von Lauterbach im Abstimmungsverhalten ja gesehen, dass er keineswegs da so äußerst progressiv ist. Also, ich weiß es nicht, was da die Leute reitet, den Lauterbach so toll zu finden. Man muss, glaube ich, sich nochmal eines klar machen. Nur, weil es eine Seite gibt, die extremistisch Leute angreift und sie bedroht und so weiter. Und das ist schlimm. Muss man nicht gleichzeitig sagen, ich muss diese Person, die da angegriffen wird, jetzt glorifizieren. Man muss diese Person vor den Angriffen schützen und muss vor allem gegen die Angreifer entsprechend mit rechtsstaatlichen Mitteln und anderen Mitteln vorgehen. Aber man muss dann nicht zugleich sagen, das ist aber jetzt hier der größte Politiker der Welt. Genauso, wenn irgendein Journalist angegriffen wird und da bedroht wird, dann muss das nicht gleichzeitig bedeuten, dass das der genialste Journalist aller Zeiten ist. Sondern es kann auch einfach ein guter Journalist sein oder ein mittelmäßiger Journalist, aber diese Angreifer hat er nicht verdient und gegen die muss man vorgehen.
Also wir auch als politische Beobachter, würde ich sagen, nehmen das Experiment jetzt gerne mit an und wahr. Wir werden uns jetzt alle anschauen, was Karl Lauterbach demnächst macht. Mich als allererstes wird jetzt interessieren, wie sieht sein Twitter-Verhalten aus die kommende Zeit. Wird sich da irgendwas einschneidend verändern? Meine Vermutung ist ja, es wird sehr viel runtergedimmt und er wird auch, und das ist neu für Karl Lauterbach, wirklich in eine Kabinettsdisziplin eingebunden, bei der es auf seine Stimme ankommt, auch wenn er nicht zum Thema. Denn das Kabinett beschließt immer alle Stimmen ab bei allen Themen. Er muss also dort seine Themen so vorstellen, dass sie tragfähig sind, auch im Familienministerium und überall sonst in der Wirtschaft, da wird er sich noch, also wenn er glaubt, er hat jetzt Gegenwind aus Sachsen bekommen, weil er auf Twitter ein paar Antworten bekommen hat, also da wird der Lobbydruck jetzt extrem auf ihn auch steigen. Und für alle Beobachter kann man natürlich noch mal darauf hinweisen, wenn einer das Ende der pandemischen Lage mit nationaler Tragweite und so weiter jetzt vehement verteidigt hat, dann war das Karl Lauterbach. Wenn einer nicht in der Lage ist, allein durch Parteiendisziplin jetzt einen Lockdown für Schulen oder so was zu beschließen, dann ist das Karl Lauterbach. Also viele Wünsche, die jetzt immer noch mittransforiert werden in diesem ganzen, erst zu Weihnachten erreichen wir die Spitze dieser vierten pandemischen Welle und so weiter, die werden sich doch sehr wundern, was sie für neuen Karl Lauterbach plötzlich zu sehen bekommen. Sei es zum Beispiel, weil sie erst mal gar keinen zu sehen bekommen und er sich jetzt auch zwei, drei Tage Zeit nimmt für politische Kommunikation und nicht gewähr bei Fuß. Ich habe die Studie auch gelesen und verteile auf Twitter noch mal gönnerhaft Renommee an diejenigen, die sie geschrieben haben und so. Also diesen Ton kann er sich jetzt nicht mehr erlauben. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich halte ihn und ich habe ihn einmal getroffen auf einem damals noch im Aufwand-Podcast, da wollten wir ihn interviewen. So in Sinne von wir haben hier eine Kamera stehen, kommen sie doch auch mal zu uns, wo sie gerade vorbei sind. Und das Verhalten fand ich unterirdisch, also wirklich unsäglich. Man hätte nicht mehr den, ich bin Professor aus Harvard, lassen sie mich in Ruhe, was sie wollen hier fürs Internet mit mir sprechen, so viel Zeit habe ich nicht und so. Auf diese Art und Weise, es war unglaublich und auch ein bisschen unpassend einfach. Es war überhaupt nicht, also hinterlässt, ohne dass das jetzt ewig nachwirkte. Also alle Kritik, die ich jetzt an Lauterbach habe, aber man erinnert sich halt jetzt wieder, wie das schon vor fünf Jahren war mit ihm, als echt ein Nobody war eigentlich für die Öffentlichkeit. Ich halte es für Olaf Scholz als ersten großen Fehler. Olaf Scholz hat mich bisher nur überrascht mit positiven Meldungen zu allem Möglichen. Also ich fühle mich jetzt, und es beginnt jetzt erst die Regierungszeit, sehr gut regiert. Aber das halte ich für ein Fehler. Sehr überraschend jetzt, dass wir es vor einer halben Stunde erfahren haben. Aber das muss Olaf Scholz jetzt selber ausbaden. Ich stehe kritisch daneben und kommentiere das, falls es irgendwen interessiert.
Lass uns noch ein kleines Detail ansprechen. Und zwar gab es ja diese 15 Minuten bei Joko und Klaas wieder auf ProSieben. Und dort erschien ja der neue Kanzler. Da war Scholz und hat gesprochen zur Nation, zu einer anderen Nation als die Nation, die man erreicht, wenn man im ZDF zum Beispiel auftritt. Wie hat dieser Auftritt auf dich gewirkt? Und was sagt das eigentlich aus, wenn der Kanzler ProSieben als Plattform nutzt, um eine solche Ansprache zu halten? Impft euch, wir wollen 30 Millionen Impfungen bis Weihnachten schaffen.
Ich glaube, es war einer der ganz wichtigen Termine vor Olaf Scholz, bei dem er auch ein bisschen Angst hatte. Er musste dazu eingeladen werden. Sie werden nie auf den Gedanken gekommen, glaube ich, im kommenden Kanzleramt, ihn da vorzuschlagen oder so. Es war also eine Idee von ProSieben, vor allem Joko und Klaas. Eine gute Idee. Und er hat sich krass darauf vorbereitet, muss man einfach sagen. Wie er sich hingesetzt hat, wie die Ansprache war. Auch der Wortlaut schützt euer Leben und so. Das ist alles spektakulär vorbereitet worden. Nützt selten etwas, wenn es dann nicht gut ausgeliefert wird. Und mir schwang immer noch Albrecht von Lucas Kommentar im Ohr. Olaf Scholz hat sich nicht aus eigener Kraft in diese Rolle gebracht, in der er jetzt ist. Er hat nicht gegen Söder und Habeck im Wahlkampf bestehen müssen, sondern gegen zwei, die auf der einen Seite was die Flut ist in meinem Bundesland. Scheiße, jetzt muss ich jemand zeigen, dass ich eigentlich regieren sollte, aber ich kann es ja gar nicht. Und Baerbock, die sich nur mit ihrem Buch rumgeschlagen hat. Also in der Ansicht Olaf Scholz ist durch Glück in diese Rolle gekommen. Saß dann aber da und Albrecht von Lucas hat kommentiert, jetzt besteht für ihn die Chance, aus seiner eigentlichen Schwäche Stärke zu machen und Seriösität mal wieder richtig zu nutzen. Wir haben ja immer uns Donald Trump angesehen und gesagt, ach so, das Gegenteil von Seriösität ist das neue Erfolgsversprechen in der Politik. Und Olaf Scholz erklärt uns gerade das Gegenteil. Nein, Seriösität, die mir immer als Schwäche ausgelegt wurde, ist die eigentliche Stärke. Und das hat er ganz wunderbar da sitzend mit dieser pathetischen Musik, die er in dem Moment wahrscheinlich selber nicht gehört hat, sondern das ist dann sozusagen, das haben wir dann nur auf der Empfängerseite so bekommen, in dieser Komposition. Aber er hat das ganz wunderbar delivered. Also ich fand das ein ganz starkes Ding wirklich auf Augenhöhe mit Merkels Es ist ernst, nehmen sie es auch ernst, Fernsehansprache. Und das war allerdings Merkels Höhepunkt medial gesehen in 16 Jahren Kanzlerschaft. Und so startet Olaf Scholz für mich jetzt da rein in seine Kanzlerschaft. Also in deren Sicht, ich finde es selber verwunderlich, aber Olaf Scholz ist ein krasser Kanzler bislang, obwohl er noch gar nicht Kanzler ist.
Und man hat sich gleich wieder auch an die Versäumnis erinnert der vergangenen Monate. Wäre es dann nicht sinnvoll gewesen, wenn Merkel sich nicht jetzt ein Jahr versteckt hätte, sondern vielleicht auch mal dann zu prosieben, ein bisschen getingelt wäre mit dieser Impfung und und und. Also man kann ja nicht da sagen, ich war da einmal bei Anne Will mit einem fahrigen Auftritt im März 2021. Und damit hat es sich jetzt, jetzt rede ich nicht mehr mit Journalisten. Ich mache jetzt wieder ein bisschen noch Abschiedstournee und bald spielen die für mich Hilde Knef. Also das ist schon sehr, sehr eigenartig, wie das gelaufen ist. Und insofern glaube ich auch, dass das an sich ein guter Auftakt ist, inwieweit dieses Publikum dann auch nochmal ein anderes ist. Bei ProSieben scheint mir auch nochmal mit Blick auf die Intensivstation nicht unerheblich zu sein. Denn diese ganz alten Leute, die zu spät geboostert werden jetzt, das ist ja ein politisches Versagen einfach. Und da ist es weniger die Frage, wollten die nicht oder konnten die nicht oder so, sondern es ist ein politisches Versagen. Während wir ja jetzt sehen bei den Intensivstationen, dass sehr junge Leute dort auch sind, die ungeimpft sind, also die 40 Jahre alt sind und plötzlich immense Probleme haben. Und die erreicht man natürlich sehr gut über ProSieben. Und das ist dann auch was, was in Facebook-Gruppen oder so noch eine Rolle spielt. Da wird in der Regel nicht mehr das Öffentlich-Rechtliche vielleicht rezipiert, sondern eher so etwas noch. Insofern ist das vielleicht kein schlechter Schachzug, das auf diese Weise zu machen.
Ja, will man die Jungen erreichen, muss man sie kollektiv erreichen, damit gleich für alle klar ist, das haben jetzt alle gesehen. Und nicht so dieses, ich hab da was gesehen im Internet, kann ich dir mal von erzählen, da muss man erst mal erzählen. Nee, das kann man dann so ein bisschen Voraussetzung. Also das ist ein bisschen dieser Lagerfeuer-Moment, der schon da ist. Und man soll sich keine falschen Vorstellungen machen, nur weil man immer hört, die Jungen hängen nur im Internet rum und so weiter. Nee, die Jungen gucken ProSieben. Also das ProSieben-Durchschnittsalter ist weit, weit jünger als das Facebook-Durchschnittsalter, wenn man sich das Publikum in Gänze mal anschaut. Das Facebook-Publikum ist größer und so, klar. Aber die Jungen schauen Fernsehen und die schauen das. Und auch die, die nicht Fernsehen schauen, bekommen dann mitgeteilt, was im Fernsehen zu sehen war. Schon allein, weil etwas, was im Fernsehen war, Thema war. Und sie als die einzigen Ausgeschlossenen im Kreise nicht wissen, was da passiert ist. Und ihnen das dann erst mal wie so ein Tratsch weitererzählt werden muss, was das alles noch mal amplifiziert. Ja, also da kommt dann nochmal mehr bei RUM. In der Hinsicht kein schlechter Stunt. Heute lesen wir Aaron Benanoff. Ja, der arbeitet in Berlin an der Humboldt-Uni, glaube ich. Und hat über Automatisierung geschrieben. Er bekennt sich selbst als linke Socke. Wir sind alle sehr gespannt, was drinsteht in diesem Buch. Ich bin vor allem gespannt, was du gelesen hast.
Ja, also es geht ja um die Frage Ist das jetzt so, dass die Roboter und die KIs und so weiter uns arbeitslos machen, droht die Massenarbeitslosigkeit und da sagt Benanef nein. Aber das Problem ist vielleicht ein ganz anderes, aber ebenso Großes. Nämlich hier geht es ganz klar auch um die Krise des Kapitalismus, in der wir uns befinden und zwar eine globale Krise, nicht nur Schwächen in der Westen oder so, säkuläre Stagnationen überall. Also das ist schon sehr erstaunlich. Er ist also nicht ein Autor, der einfach ein paar Thesen aufstellt, sondern ein Autor, der sehr viel ausgewertet hat, der sich sehr viele Daten angesehen hat und da zu interessanten Schlüssen kommt, die wahrscheinlich auch Richard David Precht irritieren werden, wenn er sie wahrnehmen könnte.
Es ist ganz vertreffliches Material für die Rentenrepublik, denn diese Krise hat sehr viel mit Schrumpfung zu tun. Irgendwann ist die Welt zu Ende ausgereizt. Und der gute Move, das gehen wir gleich im Detail durch, finde ich zu sagen, wir gucken mal in die Zukunft und machen Annahmen, indem wir uns die letzten 40 Jahre nochmal anschauen und neu erzählen, fand ich sehr gut gemacht. Ansonsten, ja, Urteil dazu später. Ja, bevor ich sage, dass ich Fassböse lese, wollte ich nochmal sagen, ich lese auch Gerhard Schick, denn es ist ein ganz wichtiger Text in den Blättern, Erbschaftssteuer, wie von Oligarchen bestellt. Das ist natürlich spektakulär. Ein ganz kurzer, ganz wichtiger Text. Ich bespreche ihn weniger, als dass ich wirklich kurz einfach die Sätze vorlese, die da drin von Relevanz sind. Gerhard Schick selber jetzt engagiert bei dieser Finanzwende-Organisation, fährt gerade eine große Kampagne zum Thema Erbschaftssteuer. Vielleicht verlinken wir das auch mal. Das ist nämlich wirklich nicht unbedeutend für uns alle. Das sollte man sich dann auch mal im Detail über den Text hinaus anschauen. Dann Flasspöhler. Ja, sie hat das Buch sensibel geschrieben. Ich kann euch meinen Urteil jetzt schon mal sagen. Die etwas älteren Philosophen vom Schlage. Richard David Precht, Theodor, die kannst du auch noch mit dazu zählen, wenn du willst.
Theodor, die wird auch so mit dazu gezählt, obwohl sie wirklich auch keine Philosophin ist.
Gerhard Scobel, Flaas Poehler, alle die Riege, die haben im Grunde ihren letzten Auftrag, den sie gerade wahrmachen. Sie zimmern sich aus ihren wirklich alten Meistern, die alle tot sind. Safe Spaces, in denen sie sich einmauern und jedes Mal, wenn man kommt und sagt, naja, Frau Flaas Poehler, wollen Sie nicht mal ein bisschen hier Realität gewährt lassen? Schon Nietzsche hat gesagt, Schubmauer hat das auch gesagt, freut sowieso und jetzt lese ich noch mal Kant entsprechend und dann sind Diskussionen üblicherweise zu Ende. Ich habe ja heute morgen auf Lektüre-Erlebnis-Ebene.
Ich habe heute morgen was gemacht. Ich hatte noch ein bisschen Zeit, bevor wir aufnehmen. Und dann dachte ich, ich lese mal die ersten 20 Seiten. Da gab es so eine Lese-Probe zum runterladen. Das habe ich dann gemacht.
Ansonsten, ich schließe dann an mit Wolfgang Michael, der in dem Freitag nochmal über den Koalitionsvertrag eine Stilkritik losgeworden ist, dort aber den Halbsatz fallen lässt. Ja, es steckt auch ein bisschen was drin im Koalitionsvertrag. Und dann springen wir rüber zu einem anderen Text in der Taz, der mal in ganz kurzen Worten die Revolution im Familienrecht aufnimmt. Und es ist wirklich ein Spektakel, was jetzt in Deutschland ansteht einfach. Ich glaube, wir setzen uns an die Spitze der Welt. Es ist wirklich krass und auch absolut zu begrüßen. Kostet alles kein Geld, kein Budget. Kann der Bundestag im Grunde jetzt im Januar noch beschließen. Also wir sind sehr gespannt, wie schnell es dann damit geht. Und außerdem reden wir heute noch mal über das Gehen und wie gut es für das Gehirn ist. Der Spaziergang. Ich möchte euch alle zu Neo-Spaziergängern machen, wie es im Text steht. Man muss jetzt diese Bewegung starten.
Prima. Ich werde noch vorstellen, das Kapital ist tot, von Mackenzie Wark. Die Autorin fragt sich, ob wir überhaupt noch im Kapitalismus leben. Dann hat Elfriede Jelinek, unsere Literatur-Nobelpreisträgerin aus Österreich, den Nöstreupreis für ihr Lebenswerk bekommen. Und sie hat eine sehr persönliche Rede gehalten, die wir uns ansehen sollten. Dann geht es diesmal nicht um Pasolini. Das schiebe ich noch ein bisschen, weil es einfach zu viel wird. Denn ich habe einen ganz grandiosen Text gefunden über die MMT. Es war ja immer das Argument, die kann man nicht anwenden in Ländern, die zum Beispiel Entwicklungsländer sind. Und da sagt der Autor, nee, so einfach sollte man es sich nicht machen. Man kann da schon sehr viel mit anfangen. Nein, nicht mit Bitcoin. Wir werden uns einen Text noch ansehen von Slavoj Zizek, den ich schon geteilt habe, den ich aber doch nochmal für wichtig erachte, zu besprechen, nämlich wie ist denn das jetzt eigentlich mit den Impfungen und dem Eingriff des Staates auf unseren Körper? Zizek hat da wirklich ein paar sehr schöne Gedanken dazu. Und was wir uns auch noch ansehen werden, so als kleiner Appetizer. Vielleicht hat ja jemand Lust, sich abends einen Drink zu machen. Wir schauen noch, was denn der Cocktail des Jahres 2022 ist.
Sehr gut. Sehr gut. Ich möchte, bevor wir gleich in den Salon gehen, noch kurz anmerken. Ich habe mich sehr gefreut über alle Hinweise zum Thema, wie könnte man die Rentnerrepublik nennen, ohne die Rentner zu sehr in den Vordergrund im Titel schon zu stellen. Das haben wir ja am Montag gemacht. Und noch am Montag, 18.45 Uhr, also eine Dreiviertelstunde nachdem der Podcast veröffentlicht war, kriege ich eine Mail von Florian, der mir vorschlägt, das Buch Opa Kalypse zu nennen. Und das ist natürlich einfach ein Spektakel. Zwei Bücher haben vertauscht und man hat es im Kern getroffen. Ich werde noch weiter sammeln bis Ende des Monats und dann die Liste einfach mal vorlegen. Opa Kalypse ist einfach ein spektakel Titel.
Es ist schön bescheuert, aber auch intelligent zugleich. Also das finde ich toll.
Es ist bescheuert und wahnsinnig intelligent. Es ist einfach grandios. Ansonsten sehr viele Wortspielereien mit Dämon, Demografie und so finde ich auch alles sehr gut. Also ich habe eine große Präferenz für einen Titel, der sozusagen googlebar ist, wo man genau weiß, also mit damit kommt man auf Platz 1, weil das ist dann nicht abgegriffen. Ja und da ist ab Opa Kalypse einfach ein Spektakel. Also in der Ansicht vielen Dank Florian, das hat mir den Montagabend noch sehr erheitert. Und allen anderen hunderten Vorschlägen auf allen Kanälen, herzlichen Dank. Wird alles ordentlich ausgewertet und fließt dann in die Inspiration ein. Gut, gehen wir mal in den Salon. Bis gleich!